Anchors Away and put on a happy face
because we have Episode five of American
Horror Story in this video we'll be
breaking down the latest episode and
you'll want to stick around to the very
end for my theory on why some ghosts are
reborn at Camp red wood and why there
are some we never see so heads up
because here we go the episode begins in
1980 four years before Brooke and the
gang arrive at Camp red wood we are here
with nurse Rita or as we've come to
learn in episode three
Donna chambers and for the purposes of
this video I'm just gonna keep calling
her Rita she's on a stakeout trying to
find out where her father has been
disappearing too after her mother told
her that he's been sneaking out and
judging by the amount of cigarette butts
outside her car Reed has been here for
quite some time for those of you really
paying attention Rose Royce's love don't
live here anymore plays in the
background which has such lines as you
abandoned me foreshadowing the death of
her father and speaking of her father we
see him get out with a woman who
definitely isn't Rita's mom Rita demands
that her father opened the door thinking
that some hanky-panky is happening but
something far worse is on the other side
the mutilated body of her father's
victim no Rita has some balls instead of
getting the hell out of there she's like
man I gotta check this [ __ ] out on the
wall are conveniently Polaroids of all
of her father's kills men women black
white it doesn't matter to him and
around the room you may have noticed
that he keeps mementos of his kills like
earrings ties belts handkerchiefs and
sunglasses when the mutilated woman so
rudely interrupts Rita she tries to stop
the bleeding
um Rita her intestines are out before
she's interrupted by dad and I love how
this brand of bleach is just called
bleach we learned that David Rita's
father has spent his entire life as a
killer and what he's about to say starts
Rita on her journey to prove that serial
killing is learned not something that
you're born with
Reeta only knows the father who loved
and raised her as a child not this evil
psychopath she doesn't want to believe
someone she loves so much can be capable
of so much evil she does disclose to him
that she's a psychologist so I think we
can put to rest theories that she was
lying about being one when she first
went to meet jingles in Episode three
she tells him he has the ability to
change but before she can change his
mind he stabs himself in the neck this
whole intro section gives us valuable
insight into Rita's motivations she
wants to prove to everyone that killers
can change that they can be redeemed
it's the same speech she gave to jingles
in Episode three telling him it's not
his fault society war trauma play
crucial roles in whether someone will be
a killer or not we also saw this echoed
with Richard Ramirez his backstory he's
constantly traumatized as a child even
witnessing his cousin kill his wife
right in front of him if Rita can prove
her theory right she herself gets her
own Redemption and peace of mind she so
wants to believe some external factor
made her dad kill that she's willing to
release a serial killer from jail just
in order to prove her point it's really
messed up and I'm here for it we're back
where last episode left off with Rita
having seen Ricky resurrect from the
dead just because something seen is
inconceivable doesn't mean that it can't
be true
he tells her that he was raised by the
unholy one and that Satan showed him
everything about her how she released
mr. jingles which led to the deaths of
several counselors pranksters and even a
porn producer he calls it to question
her very reason for being here
contradicting her theory by saying that
evil is born within you the ghost of her
father even says evil is born and you
are the fruit of its scene meaning if he
was evil it would pass on to her she is
his seed he then asked her to follow in
his footsteps so it'll be interesting to
see if she does it's also interesting to
note here that Ricky doesn't kill Rita
which leaves me wondering if this was at
satan's behest we've seen striking
similarities between Ricky and season
eights Michael Langdon but no hard
connection other than Satan between the
two outside the burning wreckage of the
porn producers car xavier goes full
psycho telling everyone that they need
to burn everything as some sort of
signal fire and it's ironic he's
obsessed with fire since he was put in
an oven last episode he's knocked out by
Margaret who says he could harm someone
but knowing that Margaret was the secret
killer all this time she's likely making
excuses to get some more kills under her
belt back in the cabin the others decide
what to do next with Margaret taking
control notice how she still has the gun
conveniently out of bullets according to
her and the deer antlers which make her
look like some sort of horned demon of
course they decide the stupidest plan of
action which is to yet again split up
and who do they make go with Margaret
I'll go with you yes the guy who just a
few hours ago was impaled with a spike
and had to be resuscitated with
adrenaline so Chet and Margaret head off
leaving Brook and Montana alone with a
passed-out Xavier Montana grabs a
hatchet and is about to kill Brooke but
she chickens out
remember that Montana wants Brooke dead
because she believes her responsible for
the death of her brother Sam Brooke runs
out after seeing ray who we know was
decapitated at the end of episode 3 if
you recall Ray's last line at the end of
the episode was sucka nut camp red would
see you in another life
well another life sounds about right as
Ray has mysteriously come back to life
and he shows the same symptom as the
hitch-hiker from episode 1 a loss of
memory Chet and Margaret row row row
their boat and at least Margaret didn't
make him row hey on the bright side Chet
you now probably qualify for the
Paralympics Margaret gets on the topic
of death probably not the best thing to
discuss after multiple people have been
murdered but she wants to know if Chet
will repent and ask for forgiveness
before she kills him he doesn't and then
we get the most brutal paddle seen since
Animal House
thank you she attaches an anchor to his
legs and makes sure to cut off his ear
to keep up the sherrod that it's jingles
responsible for these deaths ray and
Brooke have headed to the cafeteria in
the hopes of evading jingles who they've
heard in the woods
remember that jingles mysteriously
vanished after Margaret shot him but
with Ricky and Ray coming back from the
dead who the hell knows now now this
scene doesn't offer a lot in the way of
moving the plot forward but we do get a
lot of character development for Ray and
Brooke even a little kiss between the
two which I predicted in episode 1
Brooke tells us that she always had to
fake who she was in order to fit in
that's how she met Joseph Cavanaugh her
fiance even telling ray that she never
really loved him which calls into
question if she actually did sleep with
Sam Montana's brother the night before
the wedding I like to think she didn't
and the to do what any sane people would
do during a killer rampage bang Reed
arrives to the cabin after being scared
shitless by Richard Ramirez and lets it
out of the bag that she was the one to
release jingles Xavier is pissed because
his career is ruined although there is
still that porno of his around Rita says
that if they can get to her car stashed
away in the staff parking lot they may
be able to get away but Xavier attacks
jeopardizing a career for him even in
radio we see ray and Brooke post ghost
sex now is it just me or was Brooke not
too thrilled about her first sexual
encounter you know what they say once
you go ghost she goes to the fridge
still thirsty only to find Ray's
decapitated head from episode 3 and
after finding it she tells ray now this
is important because in traditional
slasher films the Virgin always survives
but we just found out she lost her v
card but is it really losing your v card
if you have sex with a ghost so keep
that in mind as we go along
rook runs back to the cabin and we
stumble upon Montana who looks to be
preparing a tent she's wanting to make
her getaway
Brooke tells Montana but Ray but before
she can barely get a word out Montana
smashes in her face with a flashlight
it's 20 minutes till sunrise and as
predicted in my last video because this
episode is entitled Red Dawn we'll
likely be seeing the rise of a bloody
new day at Camp red wood Montana beats
the crap out of Brooke and finally
reveal
her true intentions showing us how she
saw her at perfect-10 aerobics and that
she was the one to give Richard Ramirez
his blade we also get another brief
discussion on whether Montana had a
dinner to kill which echoes the question
the season is posing on whether people
are born with evil or not believe me I
wanted to kill you myself but I didn't
know if I had it in me in Montana is
introduced to one of my favorite bands
Radiohead Rita runs into the nursing
station to escape Xavier when she runs
into jingles he's not too happy he's
been brought here taking out bullets
from his last encounter with Margaret
Rita reiterates the driving force of all
her decisions and this question is
answered with jingles he was never a
killer outside the war at least it was
Margaret and the mental institution that
turned him into this monster not wanting
to live with the guilt of what she's
done she asked him to kill her but
jingles knows it'll be worse for Rita if
she's alive Montana has gone full psycho
seems to be a recurring theme this
season and battles it out with Brooke
when we stumble upon Margaret and
jingles at the archery range he's not
too pleased that she's been pinning all
these murders on him and just when it
seems like he'll have his revenge
Xavier shoots him with this shitload of
arrows when he goes over to check on
Margaret he's brutally stabbed by her
which makes me wonder if he comes back
to life will he still have those burns
and will he make a deal with the devil
to get his life back and that seems to
be what's happening with Ricky and
jingles here Ricky is offering him a
deal except Satan as his master to be
reborn
hallelujah it's finally morning at Camp
redwood after almost four episodes
completely set at night the kids have
arrived for camp and holy crap Montana
and Brooke are still fighting Brooke
ends up killing Montana in front of the
children
and Margaret pins all the murders on
Brooke now this is interesting because
she probably knows that jingles has made
some sort of deal with Ricky she was
there at the archery range and that
pinning it all on him
work anymore since well he's not there
Brooke is the next logical choice as
police and emergency services arrive at
Camp redwood Brooke is taken away and
raised blood pressure is taken but since
he's dead there's no reading forensics
finds Rey's head in the fridge and when
he's taken off camp redwoods property
he's magically brought back unable to
leave the grounds now whether or not his
physical body leaves the grounds were
not sure but it looks as though there's
a distinction between ghosts like Jonas
Sheva or aka Jason Voorhees if you
rearrange the letters in his name and
that of Ricky and jingles why is it that
Ricky and jingles get to leave but not
the others
the clue lies in Ricky's earlier
question two jingles would he accept
Satan perhaps in return for accepting
Satan you are allowed to leave Camp
bread would reborn and if you don't or
aren't even offered you stay at Camp
redwood in what Montana calls purgatory
also bonus points if you caught the
ghost busters reference a 1984 movie
when Montana says there is no Montana
only Zuul the episode also leaves us
with Ricky and jingles off to Los
Angeles now my best guess as to where
they're going is the satanic cult
in season 8 Michael stumbles across this
cult in Los Angeles so it seems like the
logical place they would go we also
don't know where Rita went her work
isn't done and she's struggling with all
the deaths she has caused perhaps she
will now seek her own Redemption and try
to go after jingles and this theme of
redemption may just be what it takes for
our campers to release them from this
cycle of purgatory every character who
has come back as a ghost so far has some
sort of traumatic past they want to be
redeemed from this is why we see some
people return as ghosts and some not and
I'm sure this isn't the last we'll see a
Brook who was seen being taken away by
police
episode 5 puts a whole new spin on the
show with characters branching out from
Camp redwood so it'll be interesting to
see how the next few episodes tie
everything together and solve some of
our most burning questions thanks for
giving the video watch make sure to LIKE
and subscribe with the Belon I have a
lot more a jazz
on the way so you don't want to miss it
be sure to leave your comments and
theories above the show below and you
can also reach out to me on twitter at
things story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much